I don't want to spend a lot of time on
this but I do want to let you know that
this guy Christopher key who is now
known for injecting urine for covid he's
been arrested this is the guy who I
previously told you
was recommending people drink urine and
then last week started recommending
people inject urine he has been arrested
organizers tasked with putting on a
Jacksonville Florida conference
headlined by coveted truthers Robert
Malone and Peter McCullough had enough
of anti-vaxxer Christopher Keys
Shenanigans they reported the vaccine
police leader to police as a trespasser
which sent him back to jail again where
he is now awaiting a preliminary hearing
key could be heard on video berating an
organizer of the far-right Gathering
after he claimed that she mandated he
moved his car off a sideway
I get is that a sidewalk is that the
same thing then he claimed he went to
the building at the take action for
Freedom tour to take a tinkle and that
led to police being called he said he
was being asked to leave
um an unidentified Gathering organizer
said to the officer that key was causing
a disturbance you've caused a big
disturbance key apparently still
wouldn't leave after being given a
trespass warning and then he was indeed
arrested now what's fascinating is he
wasn't arrested for injecting urine that
apparently is legal as long as you do it
to yourself I guess I mean it's not a
good idea it's dangerous if you hit it
if you hit a vein uh it can be very very
bad
but just trespassing and again what is
fascinating to me about this stuff as
I've said before you look at Flat Earth
you put two flat earthers in a room
together they both agree the Earth is
flat but for conflicting reasons one
will say well here's the proof that the
Earth is flat and the other will say no
that can't be true because here's my
proof and it directly conflicts with it
these anti-vax and uh sort of like covet
alternative treatment people they are
often in Conflict about why the vaccines
are bad or about what you should do
instead and you've got a big group of
people who talks about zinc and
Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine Etc
they don't want anybody injecting urine
they agree the vaccines are bad but
they're like injectier and no that
doesn't make any sense then you've got
the drink and nebulize and inject urine
people who are like zinc no way in hell
zincs um you put a heavy metal point you
know who the hell knows they conflict
with each other these people are all
Bonkers they're still holding
conferences but it's at least funny that
Christopher key ended up getting himself
arrested maybe for attention but I don't
really know what the end game is if he's
trying to get attention